he managed to kind of create something
out of nothing and as soon as the tables
turned as soon as manager have created
any threats report collapsed so um yeah
a bit of a strange first Blitz game both
players do look quite nervous uh or at
least their play looks quite nervous but
uh now no time for Nerfs it's all about
whether Rapport can go for the win and
okay is he gonna play Bishop takes
Knight oh yeah this uh I can't remember
the name of this variation but it's a
very risky one for black black Parts
with his perfect his ideal basketball
Bishop the cost of ruining the white
Pawn structure if you look at white sea
pawns double Pawns
if you just hate this but uh complex I
can give you the name it's called the
modern defense the beef eater variation
the beef eater yeah maybe I didn't even
know that no I didn't know the name
either beef is that something in front
of the castles yeah the Tower of London
there are the people with the Red Hats
Ah that's it I don't know the red suits
and black furry hats yep that's the one
and uh meanwhile there is actually quite
a lot of theory on this variation it's
kind of goes in and out of fashion a lot
of players including Magnus and Nakamura
they play this in Blitz just in must win
situations because it's so uh
strategically complex but I don't know I
think I think my colors today is really
resemble what you just mentioned sorry
colors yeah career change and meanwhile
we have seen a pawn takes Pawn on the
board I mean whites Pawn structure is
just horrific I mean is black looking at
just getting into an end game
possibly
um I mean black doesn't necessarily need
to capture this pawnback black could for
example Castle the king that could
you know step his central point forward
one square potentially
very surprised Mama jarov unless he
studied this before which he might well
have done uh I'm surprised he's kind of
played the last few moves so quickly
because White had a bunch of options
and uh okay Richard captures in the
center White's ugly pawns they're
starting to drop off but the evaluation
bar hates it wow wow wow I'm just
looking at my database someone has
played this and it was uh Nishant
against a Thurman and it was like a case
of like a David versus Goliath I mean
white one very convincingly in 20 moves
uh incredible stuff so basically white
just developed the pieces and black was
in big trouble okay so which pieces did
white develop because everyone would
sleep I sleep the night the night came
out very natural and then uh black
simply collapsed and then the queen came
out to attack the Knight
and yeah I mean essentially Black's
night is the only piece that's out in
the uh out in the game right now the
only piece that's been developed and
if it gets crazy I'm a jarov he's uh
strong enough attacking wise
to punish black for forgetting
development yeah level pawns right now
as well so we don't have to worry about
material it's all about open lines all
about speed of development yeah Knight
F3 would be natural to play here oh
Queen D5 here we go going for it yeah
hanging around no and uh the queen is of
course threatening the Knight but at the
same time she can move herself into the
into the E5 square and attack The Rook
Black's night I think needs to retreat I
don't see anything else really it looks
too brave to keep that night out in uh
out in the center maybe the Knight can
go back where it came from
my Black's Queen could jump out with a
check but I think that's just easily
blocked I don't think you can get away
with uh being too ambitious here for
black and there we go the night retreats
if the evaluation bar didn't like what
Shaq did
no it hated it because it's conventional
wisdom don't bring your queen out too
early
and now that the bar has changed its
mind it says white is better and we see
porn takes porn and you have to remember
that Shaq just needs a draw and that he
will be through to the finals yep and
now he's going to pawn up he also has
the bishop pair so unless black comes up
with something quick something creative
uh it's going to be trouble for a report
and this queen takes C5 is also
preventing black to Castle which is a
very important move to do and uh in the
meanwhile I think after Queen taxi 5
okay now the queen is being attacked and
after the queen goes and it's time for
white to develop the minor pieces yeah
quickly it's not I mean you're playing
with the queen Black's playing with
three pieces out right now
I'm slightly worried for uh namajara
okay a nice Square for the queen she
can't get kicked around here but black
and cast will find yeah black and Castle
now and I I'm sure this is like 100
Robert would do this yeah yeah and I
have to say I'm very worried about the
position here for white you know just
because of King safety the queen can
give a check back off to his car sword
and uh oh no oh Queenie seven first one
step back this was one of the reasons I
kind of added after he castles better
Rapport he's Relentless now he places a
night in the center and actually we just
assumed that the king will Castle to the
right but it's actually possible for the
king to find a nicer home on the left
side and I'm expecting the Black Knight
sitting on A6 to relocate itself to
support its uh companion yeah it's the
commentator's curse Irene at any time
either of us says like oh it's 100 gonna
be this move it's never
but uh yeah it still looks decent for
black let's see Ivanka says then on the
edge of the board can centralize Black's
Bishop can defend this night in the
center as well I have a feeling report
calculating right now where the black
and Castle either side
I'm not sure you can get away with
giving up your night yet but it's uh
it's tempting while white king is
stranded
in the center and uh time disadvantage
though for a report two minutes against
three minutes could be significant
especially because it's so chaotic right
now quite hard to calculate
he's uh yeah it feels like he's not
adapted to the pace in the first game as
well while we were interviewing Magnus
report on the clock did struggle so big
factor there
phone down low on the clock but with a
good position
and he does play after a long think the
most natural move
you see an exchange
and which way would you take back
overnight all right keep the Queen's on
okay exactly yeah go for bread
and again very crazy position on the
board I mean Black's King is ready to go
to the left the Rooks are ready to go
into the center White's King is in big
danger
move that white knight surely get
castled that's four it's too late
why do you move the Knight two that's
the question uh F3 looks like the most
natural square
is track really thinking of bringing his
Bishop out to attack the black queen why
else would you not bring your nut or
develop your knight Bishop Adria yeah
trying to deflect the black queen from
the protection of her Knight yeah but at
some point you have to Castle your king
and now if I were Richard I would be
tempted just to move my king
move the black king yeah giving up
castling rates but White's King is this
massive Target if you can get a black
Rook to the e-file you win immediately
and there we go massive threat on the
board no not E2 probably
there we go blocking the e-file so
Black's Rook can't do too much damage
and just Castle okay the work comes
attack the queen queen has to take a
step back and keep an eye on her Knight
and now the black queen has to prevent
the white king from castling
yeah this is this position is still
crazy I mean both kings in the center of
the board they're stranded I mean
Richard is material down
it's a key moment for Richard like you
said one move if White Castles he's out
of any danger he's at least going to
draw the game maybe even win it so or it
should need something now stop white
from castling Black's King is committed
okay it moves again but now white can
Castle surely yeah yeah then White's
Knight gets to the center of the board
he's missed his chance he had to stop
the king getting to safety
and uh what happens next I mean what can
black Duke attack the Queen the queen
can move away with check maybe he missed
this
unless he wants to go into an end game
he's he's going to try and get those
Queens off and trying to play against
those weak white pawns still not out of
it but white snide is very strong
but this this is consistently not what
robot had in mind before yeah so things
have gone wrong for him yeah yeah you're
100 right there just
if he had one or two more moves to kind
of get that rook in the corner into the
game go for White's pawns maybe but just
too slow time for the white Rook to
mobilize I'm thinking put it on the
seventh row put it oh and we have a
check oh this might be a killer because
White's night is coming in both of the
black Rooks are within range if the
white knight can end up on the C7 Square
it will attack and Fork both of those
Rooks
did you see manager of his eyes kind of
looked across he's got the camera up I
think
I think he's realizing he's winning this
game he's looking pretty relaxed now my
Majora's taking a sip of water and he
has lots of time Advantage yeah so yeah
you can't keep your Rooks white tonight
is going to win one of the black Rooks
and game over
in the previous tournament it was all
about the teenagers we had a bunch of
teenagers in The Knockout stage in this
one it's the oldest player in the
tournament
37 looking like he's gonna make it all
the way to the big final to fight for
the title experience still matters in
chess now the White Knight it doesn't
even need to rush to take the Rooks yeah
maybe delay it but I would yeah before
they run away capture that rook in the
corner and uh then just uh pin step
forward with your Rook to the fourth row
pin the bishop and I just can't see any
situation where white is going to go
wrong and uh well Shakura decides to do
what David suggested just that mover
work Knight takes work so you take the
work now and then F4 yeah yep double pin
double pen yeah Black's Bishop sorry
sorry and then you can relax after this
like because this spin is going to be
forever yeah unless there would be an
exchange of The Works which would be in
what's favor
yeah so even if the black Bishop can
move which it has to now yep
too late
and White's favor Bishop can't compete
Against The Rook when there's pawns on
both sides of the board
Plex King is active though I'm trying to
look for little
uh plus points little glimmers of hope
and Rook steps back gives a check
everything is protected
I guess the white king could also make a
move towards those pawns on the right if
he just pushes his Pawn forward this is
just very nice strategy all his pawns
are safe and it is in the bag for chakra
and it's a kind of nice that they finish
off for a Richard reporter tournament
with a rook versus Bishop
kinda thank the chess Gods thank Kaiser
Bishop versus Rick today that would have
been a bit of a dampener but okay
Richard still has an idea look at this
he's going to try and cut the
coordination between the white rook and
that a pawn he's going to win it but
White's King is going to come across and
cut off the black king if it captures
and just before you thought it was going
for 50 minute roll they pushed upon
that's right and
yeah just when Rapport maybe thought he
had some chance winning that a pawn
is now for black his King is in the way
the black king is trapped
you can barely move now uh for a report
you can move your Bishop but no real
chance anymore this uh manageriff
doesn't even want to win he's repeated
the position now uh this is the second
time we've seen this position if the
bishop moves again he'll happily keep
repeating that order
report 10 seconds as well closing in on
his last 10 seconds
it's Bishop
he's got to play for a win and it's the
same as a draw in this one and Mama
jarath advancing against pawns imagine
also his Rook will come to the seventh
and he will repeat the position once
more a draw is good enough to win and
secure a place into the finals yeah what
a final that's going to be oh yeah it's
uh two of the most informed players the
players who topped the prelims as well
uh dude
just so informed right now both of them
uh sometimes inconsistent those two
that's been the one criticism leveled at
them but not this tournament they've
just been fantastic they both deserve to
be there okay a check probably King
before first two one second oh
so close yeah oh yeah and my majority
would just repeat the moves again
it's over
makes it to the big final of aim chess
rapid water